Welcome back. I hope that your
mental stack has not overflown
because of all the recursion.
In this second part we'll keep it
very light
and in particular I will help you
with some of the exercises that
are on the website for this chapter.
In the very first lecture we showed
very quickly an implementation of
quicksort
in Haskell and what we will do now is
we will
look in a little bit more detail
at quicksort in Haskell.
The idea of quicksort is to sort a list
recursively by decomposing the list
somehow
recursively sorting those lists
and then combining the results together.
If we
think about that for a little bit,
we can say:
if I have the empty list it's already
sorted.
Now how do we
recurse how do we break up that
list
into two parts that we can recursively
sort
and then easily combine the results to
get a sorted list?
Well what we do is if we can take a look
at the head of the list
and break this list in two, one with all
the values that are
less or equal than the head. One with all
the values that are greater than the head.
Then we can just recursively sort
those two lists and inject the head
in the middle and we're done. That's
the algorithmic essence
of quicksort but as I already
warned you
in the real implementation you're not
creating new lists
you're really mutating
the data structure in place to swap
the elements and that's an aspect that
this version of quicksort
doesn't show but it does show this
recursive
structure. Alright, here's the
implementation of quicksort
similar to the very first lecture
and only now it's called quicksort
instead of f.
What we do when we have the
empty list:
it's already sorted. When we want to sort
a list
x cons xs
we create a list with all the elements
that are smaller
or equal than x, and for
that
we use a list comprehension. We create
a list of all the elements that are
larger than x.
We sort both of those and we put
x in the middle. This
is a very simple implementation of
quicksort
but again it's also a very simplistic
implementation of quicksort. But if you
want to understand the structure
this is probably a very good
illustration.
If we want to
illustrate how this works, let's
abbreviate quicksort as q
such that the slide doesn't
overflow. We want to sort
the list 3 2 4 1 5. What we're going to
do is we're
taking the head three and we're going to
break up the rest of the list
into the elements that are less than
equal to 3 and the ones that are
larger than three.
The elements that are less in this list
are two
and one. And the ones that are larger
are four
and five. That's what you see,
we recursively sort
those and we inject three in the
middle.
If we sort the list
2 1, we take the head, we split
the remaining list, which is just
one, into the values that are smaller
and the values that are larger.
The ones that are larger that's the
empty list.
The ones that are smaller that's one and
then
we drop two
in the Middle. Same on the right
hand side,
we take the first element
and we split the remainder of the list
which is just 5
in the elements that are larger than four
so that's the list 5
and the elements that are smaller which
is the empty list
and we inject four there
in the middle.
The empty lists here and here
are already sorted so nothing to do
there.
We just have to short the list
of one
element and you can verify that when you
sort the list of one element it returns
that list itself. If we
make those recursive calls there
we get this list and now you see
that the result is one two
three four five.
You just walk that three
to get the results.
That was quicksort.
The exercises for this week there's a
lot of exercises to define
functions recursively but I'm going
to
do just a couple of them here
with you. Let's look at the first one
here. It says
produce a list with n identical
elements so
that's a function that takes an integer
which is
the n and then it takes a value
a and it should return a
list of n copies of
that value a. How do we do that?
Well we do that by not recursing,
well we don't recurse
over this a, and we have to build the
list,
so what we have to do is we have to
define this
recursively over the structure of
this
integer so again we have two cases.
n equals 0, if I replicate an
element 0 time,
I get the empty list so that case
is easy.
If I want to replicate a value
n times, what do I do? I first
replicate it
n minus one times, so I get the list
of n minus one times as, and
then I cons
a on top. That one is easy
but again you have to look a little bit
and them you see: I'm doing recursion
over that guy, there's two cases
just
write them down and everything drops out.
Here is
another friend of us that we've
seen in previous lectures
and there I warned you that in Haskell
lists don't have constant access.
When we implement this function that
will be very clear.
What we have to do is we have to take
a list and a number
and then return the element in that
list
at that position. Of course we can do
this
using a take or drop or other
functions but the goal here is to
define it
using recursion. Since we have here
two recursive structures, the list
and the integer, we're going to
define this by recursing
over both. How
would that look, well first thing is if
we want to have the zero'th element
of the list, well that is the head of the
list.
If I have a list x cons xs
and this one is zero then that's
the element. For the first element of
the list
is the element at index 0.
That's a simple one.
If the list here is
empty,
well what do we.
That's a good question, probably if
I want to index the
nth element of the empty list
that's going to give an error.
Let's not worry about that, we're going
to put that as the last clause.
Now we can assume that
this one is not zero and this one is not
empty.
If that one was zero we're done, if that one
was empty
and this one is not zero then we have an
error. Now they're both non-zero so
what we do
is we say: okay if this is
x cons xs and this is n what we do
is we take the index of the tail of the
list
and the n-1 index.
Simple recursion too, it's just that we
have to be a little careful
about the base cases. The last
function we're going to define
using recursion here, decides
if a given value is a member
of a list. Of course
we could cheat here and not use
recursion. We can
easily use filter or list comprehension
or something, but the goal here is
to define this
function using recursion. In this
case
there's an obvious candidate to do
the recursion
over, that's this list. If we're
looking for an element a
in the empty list, that's false.
That element is not in the list.
If we're looking
for an element a in the list x cons xs,
well we have to check whether the head
of the list
is equal to the value that we're
looking for.
If that's the case we return true.
If that's not the case
then we just search for that element in
the tail of the list.
Eventually the tail of the list
will be empty
so we will hit the base case and we're done.
Now you see here that since we're
checking equality of this element
each head of the list until we find it
the type a must support
equality and that's what you see here in
the type. So
we can only search for a value in a list
if the types of the list support equality
and that's why we get this constraint
here so a must be
a member of the type class Eq of a.
Great, I hope that this
helped, these small exercises
and as I said: on the website
there's a lot of exercises where you
will do
recursion and if you get stuck
try eating a banana and maybe it helps.
Or maybe you can two eat bananas,
and that will work even better.
See you next week.